[Music]
We took care of him, praise be to God, Lord of the worlds, and we
immediately published it on social media. Adoption is forbidden. We
must give time to people. Even my blessings are playing
with his mother. We are alive. Glory be to God. His father is coming out from under the titles. Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds. I left behind an energy that I am breathing from.
The child, Ibrahim, my son, is beside me, and I am
hearing his voice.  But I am not good. I mean, I am not good at
raising myself. My
second son, who is missing, Mustafa, was also beside me at
the time. They helped me and took me out. The civil defense came, may God
reward him well. They also took out
my son Mustafa. Ibrahim is with me. This is my son. This is my son. I do
n’t know anything about him. You will be
surprised after they came to a sister like this and your second son said, “
Okay.”